Film Courage: Scripts are just awful when
the writer tells you everything?
Wendy Kram, Owner of LA4Hire: Did I say that?
Oh…a friend of mine said that who she’s
not a screenwriter, she’s not a producer,
she’s been in the business.
She’s a publicist and she has exquisite
taste in films.
And I remember asking her because I was asked
for I think a topic of an article and I said
“What would you say is one of the things
that has made you want to get involved with
a script.
And what do you think makes a script really
good?”
And she said “What makes scripts awful is
when characters tell you everything.”
And so if a husband and a wife and let’s
say a wife saw her husband having lunch with
another woman that she didn’t know about.
And he comes home from work and he’s like
“Hi, Honey?
How was your day?”
And if she were to say…what she will probably
say in real life was “Nothing.”
With that kind of…and Mad Men is the master
of subtext and I recommend looking at just
about any episode of Mad Men.
Much less interesting…Or the husband comes
in and says “What did you do today?”
And I was in a similar situation once and
I did not say “I saw you having lunch with
another woman today.”
I wanted him…I wanted to maybe catch him
in a lie.
I said “What did you do today?”
And he said “Nothing special.”
“Did you have lunch somewhere interesting?”
“What are you talking about?”
And like maybe one of the things that I love
is that if you really play along that you
can also play with the audience in terms of
thinking “Oh yeah, he was having an affair.
It was an interior decorator and he was surprising
his wife with he just bought a little vacation
home.
And he was making sure or he was renting in
Malibu a place and he wanted to make sure
all the stuff was special for their anniversary.
And then what can happen is she keeps testing
him and testing him and starts bringing up
old stuff about how he pisses her off, that
scene could end with not telling her what
the surprise was and the couple deciding “You
never trust me.
You know what, I was going to do something
nice for you and scr*w you!
I want a divorce.”
I’m just spinning here and I’m not saying
that that’s the greatest scene but that’s
an example when you play with subtext versus
characters saying everything that they’re
thinking.
Another example if you take A STREET CAR NAMED
DESIRE with Blanch and Stanley and Stella
and if you had Blanch saying “Well, I really
have been working and I’m
depressed and I have no where else to live.”
Game over!
So if you think about it in those terms.
And it’s really reflecting how people are
in real life, people don’t always say exactly
what they are thinking and feeling.
Film Courage: Oh, not at all.
But that’s what makes it so interesting,
too.
Because you said going along on the ride wondering
will there be a raised eyebrow that will reveal
something?
Wendy Kram: Exactly because then it just has
this flat tone and it really doesn’t replicate
human life and I feel like that’s one of
the things that said earlier when you asked
what I love about movies is that we can vicariously
put ourselves in the other character’s situation.
And we can say “I’ve been in a situation
like that.
I didn’t want to confront my husband with
another woman” and so on and so forth.
Film Courage: Or like you can tell if there
is gossip or somebody said something about
you, so they come in “How are you?”
Wendy Kram: Oh, exactly!
Film Courage: And you know that they want
something from that statement.
Wendy Kram: And then we can immerse ourselves
in the person who is suspecting that maybe
they were talking about her but they are not
coming out and saying it.
But I think that’s such as great point that
it really engages us so much more and because
that’s a comment that came up before.
You want to be engaged.
I mean, good writing, good script, scripts
that command attention with an extraordinary
capacity to engage your reader and that’s
usually through really smart dialogue like
what you were talking about.
Film Courage: You talked about too scripts
that don’t propel the character forward.
So can we have some examples of ones that
do it and ones that don’t or just some themes?
Wendy Kram: So gosh, okay…Breaking Bad is
such a great example of an escalation of situations.
So I would say that in the character, every
step that he takes there’s a consequence
and it leads to another and another and then
the character and then the character might
try to get himself out of it but it’s kind
of like the notion of McBeth.
Once you create or do something bad, it has
its own momentum.
It’s hard to say without really doing specifics
but basically every scene you want to feel
that you’re advancing the story, you’re
advancing the plot.
Even if the character has a set back that
there’s still…one of the best ways to
think about it is that there’s the core
spine of the story where the character, where
you may have an ensemble that each has a goal
that there is a primary objective that the
character is trying to obtain and the obstacles
that get in the way that prevent them from
that.
And how they (even if it’s a step back)
but then they’re still trying to overcome
that obstacle.
Most movies (successful movies) follow that
formula.
I hate to say formula because I don’t like
things being formulaic.
And an example really where stories are not
propelled forward is when the writer loses
focus (the focused is too diffused).
And one of the common reasons for that would
be when there are too many characters.
When a writer is introducing so many characters
that rather than get to know one or a few
really well, we’re getting glimpses of all
of these different characters but none of
them (because they don’t have time to develop
them particularly well) and so we don’t
have a core sense of a character’s primary
focus or a group of character’s primary
focus.
And the goal is what are the obstacles that
get in their way.
So I think any time there’s a really diffuse
focus, then scripts don’t…they wind up
just being very dispersed, rather than having
a through line.